india's capital delhi is going into a
six-day lockdown
as authorities contend with a huge surge
in covet-19 cases
delhi's chief minister says the city's
health system has reached its limits
and harsh measures are needed to prevent
its collapse now the number of
confirmed new infections has been
breaking records almost
daily
many in india thought they had got the
better of the pandemic
but now the country is being overwhelmed
by a devastating new wave
no city is as badly hit as delhi
as cases explode hospitals there are at
breaking point
some patients are forced to share a bed
and there's an acute shortage of oxygen
the city's chief minister says the
system has reached
its limits
19 patients are filling up rapidly
patients are being admitted to the
hospitals very quickly
intensive care beds are in short supply
and less than 100 icu beds are available
in delhi
authorities in delhi had already imposed
a lockdown
over the weekend ordering orbit
essential services to close
local leaders hope the decision to step
up the measures
will help to mitigate the crisis some
welcome the restrictions
but others fear if they're not allowed
to work the consequences
could be drastic
it is essential that there's a lot down
here because right now
the virus is spreading a lot
the problem with the lockdown is as
daily wage earners who get 100 to 300
rupees a day
where will we go how will we eat where
will we sleep
is the government going to come and give
us this daily wage
but now with one in three tests in delhi
turning out positive
the government says it must act to avert
a greater disaster
the fear is that the surging cases is
due to a new more
infectious variant of the virus they're
calling on people to be more disciplined
about sticking to the rules
but critics are also asking why
religious festivals
and political rallies that are fueling
cases
as participants return to cities like
delhi are still being allowed
to go ahead
for tens of thousands of families such
questions
come too late and if current trends
persist
then many more will find themselves in
the same tragic
situation
[Music]
and i'm now joined by dw correspondent
manila children who's in delhi
uh good to see you manira so india has
just registered its biggest ever
increase in corona virus cases with more
than
270 000 in a single day
what is driving this
what exactly has triggered such a
contagious second wave which is far more
uh infectious than what we saw last year
but there are experts who are saying
that the new
mutant variant the new strain as we're
calling it has something to do with it
it is far more contagious than what we
saw
in the first wave last year but another
thing to note is that there are large
gatherings which were allowed to take
place for months
including the kommela which is one of
the largest hindu religious festivals
hundreds and thousands of people every
day were gathered in one place and after
gathering there these people have
been going back to different states in
different hometowns taking perhaps the
infections along with them
apart from that different political
parties including the bharatiya janta
party which is the national ruling party
have been organizing election rallies in
different states
so allowing such gatherings to happen
and actively organizing such
gatherings has a lot to do with why we
are in this situation
manera india is is the world's
leading maker of of raw vaccines
how is the country's own inoculation
program
doing well india had been struggling in
the past few weeks there were reports
from at least
10 states which had raised concerns that
they were running out of vaccine supply
i myself did a report last week from a
town an
hour away from the capital city of delhi
uh in which multiple hospitals had to
stop the vaccination process from
for two days and some for seven days
because they had run out of supply as
well
and even the max vaccine manufacturers
had been saying that they are running
out of capacity they are not able to
meet the demand
the latest on this is that the
government has finally provided some
more financial support to the vaccine
manufacturers
in the hope to ramp up the production
also because from may 1st
the government is opening up the
vaccination process to everyone above
the age of 18.
now countries around the world have have
put india on a no travel list uh the
british prime minister ross johnson has
just cancelled a planned visit to india
what impact is this likely to have on
the nation
well if you just talk about uk at the
moment then definitely this move will
cause panic also because only three day
notice has been given
so there's a lot of uncertainty
surrounding such travel plans
uh but yes boris johnson as we know was
supposed to come to india to talk about
a trade deal and in the indian economy
has been suffering quite a lot uh since
it said the government imposed a
lockdown last year we've all seen that
so in terms of business as well in terms
of trade such
travel ban being imports will definitely
have implications on the trade
side as well all right that's manira
chaudhary
reporting for us in daily thank you
manira
you